لقاح يخلص المريض من السرطان دون الحاجه
لعمليات استئصال او جرعات كيميائيه حلم
راود الكثير من مرضى السرطان الذين عانوا
لاعوام من الورم الخبيث اليوم الحلم على
وشك ان يصبح حقيقه حيث توصل علماء في
امريكا الى لقاحات قادره على تقليص
الاورام ومنع السرطان من العوده الى الجسم
تلك اللقاحات لا تزال قيد التجربه ويتم
اختبارها حاليا على المتطوعين اللقاحات
تشبه بطريقه عملها العلاجات المناعيه فهي
تعزز من قدره الجهاز المناعه على العثور
على الخلايا السرطانيه وقتلها اما التجارب
حاليا فتركز على سرطاني الثدي والرئه على
ان تتجه لاحقا لمرضى سرطان الجلد القاتل
والبنكرياس واذا ما ثبت نجاح هذا اللقاح
فان العلماء يتوقعون طرح المزيد من
اللقاحات في غضون السنوات الخمس المقبله